لقد كان مزدوجًا
المواجهة تبدو مبتذلة للغاية
ما أقوله لك لكنه لا يزال هناك
واقع هذه الليلة ليس هناك القضاء عليه
لا يوجد أشخاص مؤهلون، هذا هو الواقع
إنه الواقع وأنا أذوب كثيرًا
من الأمل كان لدينا
مناقشة في غرفة خلع الملابس مع
مع لاعبي فريقي، ها نحن ذا أجرؤ
نأمل أن نجد بعض
نضارة في ثلاثة أسابيع أننا ذاهبون
استعادة اللاعبين أننا سوف نكون قادرين على
إجراء مثل هذه الدورات الكبيرة
دون الانتهاء
الفريق ومن ثم ستكون هناك مباراة
اللعب إذا كان لدينا القدرة على ذلك
لنكون قادرين على اللعب كما لعبنا
آخر 25-30 دقيقة مضت
يمكن أن يكون الأمل في الفوز في
فوز بايرن على بايرن يمكن أن يساعدك
يؤدي إلى العقوبة التي يمكن أن تقودك
أيضا إلى المؤهل